such a pleasure to chat with you both hi
hi carlos of what i've seen so far this
series i am
obsessed guys obsessed and every season
you seem to just raise the stakes you
level up heidi can you tease anything
that you're doing differently this
season to do just that raise the stakes
level up i mean i feel like the
designers are getting um stronger and
stronger i feel like you know they have
now seen two seasons so they're all
coming out of the woodworks you know
because it is um a special thing when
you participate in a reality um
competition show because you're putting
your talent and you
on the you know for the world to see
which is not an easy thing to do and
especially designers you know they can
at times be very fragile because you
know they work kind of in their space
and then their clothes are the ones that
do the talking so all of a sudden you
know when they're in front of the camera
you know a lot of people don't want to
do that so but now they see how big of a
show this is you know how great it is
for
their business you know we get seen in
over 260 countries around the world and
every week they have the opportunity to
get a winning look that gets them
produced and sold in our store on amazon
so it's a win-win situation for them and
they have the opportunity to get a
million dollars so the odds are pretty
good when it's only 10 contestants you
know it's
you know you could possibly get that
million dollars and really get your
business to the next level plus with the
helps of amazon you know it's a huge
company
and so um yeah so this year they ran our
door down and so we have 10 amazing
designers from around the world and
they're the ones that make it special
you know it's not like we are trying to
reinvent the wheel we're making
beautiful clothes and there's a
shoppable aspect where people can buy
these clothes but really the show
you know lives from those people and
they are the stars
tim the grades
we see you spend quite a bit of time
with the designers when you have your
tim talks uh when someone
you know when you give someone some
advice
and they don't take it is that is that
frustrating to you or do you find
yourself often surprised by the results
may be pleasantly surprised by the
results
um
more pleasantly surprised carlos um
my goal when i'm having the tim talks is
to get the designer to see what i'm
seeing before i say it because then you
know
they understand they see it and then
it's their decision to make it's it's
not my work um when when people ask do
you feel guilty when someone goes home
do you feel that you didn't give them
the right advice no just as i don't
pat myself on the back when they win i
mean i'm it's their success and it's
it's their
their loss
um so it's really more about getting the
designer to be as objective as possible
because it's it's extremely difficult
it's your work um how do you step away
from it and and have even a modicum of
objectivity
i think it's hard sometimes for them um
to see their designs from a different
point of view because they're so in it
so on top of it and sometimes it needs a
tim talk or it always does you know when
you come and then they're like oh okay
so then they see
it from a different point of view their
own
piece like they step for the first time
more away from it and look at it
in a different way so it gets them
thinking again you know and that's the
goal
yeah uh heidi your
relationship has been described as a
marriage
you and tim here what uh what do you
love most about working together
um
we love the same things we love fashion
and we love finding a great designer at
the end of the day
that's why we're in it i mean tim has
been a teacher for many many years you
know and i've modeled for many many
years and kind of you know designed a
little bit but we all live in this
fashion bubble we love this fashion
bubble we love being surrounded
by creative people that's what we both
still thrive off and love you know
because some people are like isn't this
getting boring how can this be boring
because fashion always moves it's like a
tornado there's new things coming in and
out all the time and you know so it's it
it still is super exciting because there
are not uniforms that these people are
making you know it's not the same the
same the same they you know i get mind
blown what they do in a short amount of
time and
so that's still thrilling to both of us
it is and i'll just add that heidi and i
take the fashion into industry with with
great doses of seriousness at the same
time we know you've got to have fun
tim is there anything that you would
tell the uh tim and heidi from 18 years
ago about what your working relationship
might be like
well
there's a commonality which is i'm still
completely and totally in awe of heidi
but now there's also a comfort level
because we are like a married couple
no and it is amazing but you know even
though we've been doing this for so long
you know sometimes we do a tv show
together or whatever and we hold hands
before we go on and we both are nervous
we both have like our sweaty palms
holding each other and you know i feel
like even though you know we look older
now we've become older we're still at
heart the same people we were 18 years
ago when we met each other and um it's
just we know each other better
oh yeah
you know we're still the same people and
we still have the same goal
the remarkable thing is carlos i'm older
heidi isn't
i am still breathtaking
i put a little vaseline on the on the
thing here that's what it is
we see social media play a big role this
season heidi are you
happier or maybe not happy that you
started your career before the advent of
social media do you think it would have
been an advantage to you or are you
happy that you didn't have it back then
i'm not a person that thinks about
coulda shoulda woulda i didn't have it
um i mean if it would have been there
you know you would probably see more
swimsuit bikini shots of me on the beach
no but i don't know i just you know i
yes i would have loved it but i don't
think about it because i didn't have it
what i think about now is there's many
amazing opportunities that come with it
for all these different designers
because if you are young or or not even
young doesn't matter how old you are
designer from like some small
town in the middle of nowhere you can be
seen right now on social media you know
before someone had to drive into that
little town possibly see that little
store and possibly go in there and buy
something
but now you have the opportunity with
social media that people can see you
and you know in the places where it
possibly matters you know someone could
you know land on my on my feet and then
i see them i'm like oh my gosh who's
this person like before i could have
never seen that person
so it's it's a win and it's a loss at
the same time because now also the pool
of designers all of a sudden has grown
so much more because there's a gazillion
of them now
so for the designers it's a little
trickier also that they have to really
cut through the noise and they have to
make themselves seen and heard through
their clothes
but so is life you know so you have to
just keep pushing yourself to be seen
and
now people have the opportunity through
social media that we get to see them
fantastic well thank you so much for the
time you two the show looks great the
fashion's tremendous uh so happy to talk
to you thank you carlos
you